so you've banished the cult taking the
outpost and now you're wandering around
spoiling for a fight but not really
finding it what do you even do at the
end of Far Cry 5 we've got some ideas to
help you out let's talk games
live events our first bit of advice is
on Tuesdays and buried in the menu
seriously it's not that easy to find but
if you can get there go sign up for live
events each week they consist of
challenges that give you new outfits and
weapons week one saw sliding animals on
fire without using a flamethrower or a
Molotov cocktails which was actually a
lot of fun week two as players heading
over to arcade which we'll get to in a
bit we're not sure yet if these live
events will keep hall and valley
interesting farcry doesn't have any rare
weapons to chase our particular reasons
to chase them like gear sets in the
division but we've had fun coming back a
few hours on Tuesdays and screwing
around with a friend we'll keep doing it
while the challenges are fun and the
rewards are good enough remember that
you can reset all the outposts in the
game once you've beaten the story and
that helps find reliable fights quite a
lot arcade if you've had enough of
Montana and want some escapism from your
escapism then maybe it's finally time to
listen to what this obnoxious NBC has to
say
this games awesome you can play with
your friends
you gotta try this best game ever far
cry arcade lets you create chair and
play maps with the community while the
quality can vary quite a bit there's
some real gems out there if you know
what to look for the best part is that
folks like you are uploading new maps
constantly so every time you fire up the
game there's gonna be something new and
if that's not enough of a draw every
time you level up in arcade you get a
bit of cash or skill points that you can
use in the story
there's even PvP if you can find a match
fishing for some reason a lot of you are
searching for fishing on the Internet
I'm just gonna assume you all want to
relax at a nice stream or lake and haul
in a nice bit of peace and quiet + cache
fish for a lot of cash maybe even want
to fish with a friend work together to
land that one that got away
build a freaking airforce at the start
of Far Cry 5 when you're trying to
escape across the bridge and a federal
agent is like oh my god they have an Air
Force well some odd hours later we have
a freaking airforce and it's our end
game obsession first off you have to
fully commit to the idea of air power by
hiring the king and queen of the skies
so if you need a pilot who can shoot the
dick off a gopher from the 50 feet in
the air I'm your girl grab Adelaide
Redmond by completing her set of
objectives over at the German marina and
Nick arrived from Ryan Suns aviation who
can perform strafing and bombing runs as
well as shoot down enemy planes with a
helicopter and plane above you it may
sound like you live on an airport runway
but that's kind of the idea next treat
yourself to one of the better
helicopters in the game or if you don't
have the cash and haven't done this
already go straight to the pin k0 radar
station and liberate it to unlock one
for free personally we like the 8:04 B
Fox fly with its guns rockets flares and
high speed maneuvering we're still not
clear on whether flares in this game but
it looks cool for even more fun bringing
a buddy and start tooling around
swinging from the bottom of their
helicopter or have them ride in the back
and blow crap up you want to take a
helicopter that has more than two seats
because if they're stuck is the co-pilot
they'll only be able to use their
secondary weapon and that's it fly low
hop from place to place quickly and get
some of that fun back
so are you messing around with Arcade
hitting the live events hunting or
fishing or just waiting for the first
DLC to drop what do you enjoy doing
after the campaign in Far Cry 5 give us
your best suggestions in the comments
below and thanks for watching
she did it
[Music]
you